So what is a habit,
and I think the key thing about a habit
really comes down to decision making
because sometimes people think about
it's something that you do repeatedly,
you know it unfolds over time,
but really the key thing about a habit
is that you're not making a decision.
You're not deciding whether to brush
your teeth,
you're not deciding whether to use the
seatbelt,
you're not deciding whether to go to the
gym first thing in the morning,
you've already decided,
and the advantage of a habit is that
once some things on automatic pilot,
then the brain doesn't have to use any
energy or willpower to make a decision.
You've already made that decision.
You're just moving forward.
And so it happens easily without any
thought,
without any willpower,
with any,
without any effort.
You're just on cruise control.
And then you can do what you want to get
done.
How that is like the invisible
architecture of everyday life.
Research shows that something like 40
percent of what we do every day,
we do in pretty much the same way and in
the same context.
So it's easy to see that if you have
habits that work for you,
you're much more likely to be happier,
healthier,
and more productive.
If you have habits that don't work for
you,
it's really going to drag you down
because it's a big part of our days is
taken up by habits.
What are the mysteries of habit system?
Why do we persist in having bad habits
when we know they're not good for us,
when they know they don't make us happy,
but you know there's usually multiple
things going.
Maybe it's what you want right this
minute versus what you want on the
longterm,
or maybe you want to.
Things that are in conflict.
On the one hand,
you want to have plenty of time to hang
out and goof around.
On the other hand,
you want to have a clean,
pleasant department.
So you have two things that are in
conflict.
So when you have a bad habit,
it's very helpful to think very clearly,
what do I really want over the longterm?
What's what's really most important to
me?
And that can help you fight back against
the pole.
That gravitational pull that a bad habit
can exert.
One of the things people say about how
this sometimes is they're like,
make healthy choices and I completely
disagree.
Don't make healthy choices,
make one healthy choice,
and then no more deciding.
The reason that habits can give us so
much more power in our lives is that
they eliminate the need for decision
making.
You can just decide one time what you're
going to do and then you don't revisit
that decision because every time we make
a decision we have the opportunity to
decide wrong and even if we decide
correctly,
we still are using a lot of energy to
battle with that decision.
So you really want to use decision
making to set out a habit that you want
and maybe to anticipate a lot of the
challenges,
a lot of the stumbling blocks that you
might encounter along the way as you're
trying to form that habit.
But once you've made that decision,
don't look back the side once and then
no more deciding.
One question is whether you're better
off trying to do one habit at a time.
If you're trying to make change or
whether you do many all at once and like
many things with habit formation,
there's just no magic answer.
There's no one size fits all solution.
Some people do better when they start
small.
When they keep it very simple and they
gain the habit of the habit,
they get a feeling of accomplishment and
it's very manageable and realistic
because it's something very small and
it's just like one thing,
but on the other hand,
there are some who love to go big,
big transformations and big challenges
and so something to do is to think about
yourself and think,
well,
what have I succeeded in the past?
Or what appeals more to my nature?
And you think about what works for you
because there really isn't one perfect
way to change a habit or to change a
bunch of habits.
It really depends on what's going to
work for you.